he is the one the only of sunday night
football
football night in america fresh off of
calling the
bills and the ravens he is now michaels
how are you al i'm great rich what uh
what a weekend huh
it was i mean sunday's games were were
dynamite um
and saturday's games uh were intense no
question about it um what did you see in
the bills that makes you think you know
you've seen championship teams before do
you see one
from that one in front of you al what do
you think i think they have a chance and
i to me going into the game and chris
and i we were talking about it you know
all week long going into it
and felt you know the whole thing would
be
could the bill's defense take care of
the ravens offense
i'll say you held them to three points
no touchdowns
leslie frazier the defensive coordinator
of the bills what a plan he came up with
uh and that won the game for them and
clearly
when it was 10 to 3 and then you get the
interception
by johnson and the 101 yard run back
one of the great things i think about
sports rich is that you never know who's
going to be the big star the big hero
come up with the unexpected
moment i mean up until that point the
greatest uh
and most dramatic interception i ever
called was malcolm butler
in the super bowl against seattle
and you wouldn't have thought of malcolm
butler as the guy who would be the big
hero in that game he was
the fifth or sixth defensive back and in
this particular game you know who's
going to be a big star who's going to
make
the interception at the end of not the
at the end of the game but the game
turning interception true davious white
would it be jordan poyer would it be
levi
wallace would it be micah hyde you would
think maybe
tremaine edward edmonds one of those
guys would be the guy but no out of
nowhere comes uh
tyron johnson to be the to be the big
star heck of a play
unbelievable interception and then just
i guess you know looking at it on the
replay for
maybe a split second he's thinking about
going down in the end zone you know he's
in the end zone do you want to come out
with it
and take a chance and then uh that only
took about a quarter of a second and off
he went and
and nobody was going to catch him well
and uh the next day on game day morning
when i
i was uh doing the highlight we were all
getting on curt because you called the
james harrison reception as well on your
last game you call with madden in that
super bowl
i mean you've you've called some long
ones yeah i mean
you think about it i mean the butler
picked that was it and he went down
immediately and
they ran the game out from the the one
or two yard line the harrison play
may be the most amazing play ever piece
when you think about it it's the end of
a long
drive for the cardinals so
the defense has to be a little gassed at
that point
and then kurt throws the pass and then
harrison picks it off
and goes a hundred yards right down the
sideline
and of course the the classic shot of
larry fitzgerald trying to weave his way
through the
bench some of his guys are getting in
the way but what but people forget about
that play not only a hundred yards
for the touchdown and instead of arizona
having the lead
now pittsburgh's got a two possession
lead but he barely gets into the end
zone and as you recall richard he
doesn't
the clock has expired they can't even
kick a field goal
so that to me you know people say what's
the most iconic
single play you've seen that might be it
and then the san antonio homes catch
which came you know at the end of the
of of the game might be the second most
i mean we've talked about that 08 super
bowl and and to me that was
that's the classic of classics now
michael's here on the rich eisen show
talking to josh allen and mcdaniels
though uh i mean with uh mcdermott
uh al it just again this this is the
team
you know green bay we all know about
green bay and tampa has been
obviously uh down and out but they do
have brady and mahomes and
we're assuming he will be healthy enough
for the game like talking to chad henny
in the third hour
um that you know the chiefs of the
chiefs right now we're all water skiing
behind their yacht but the bills
they're kind of now the last team
standing that's carrying the mantra of
the
you know why not us uh it's been too
long
they don't know maybe what they don't
know type of attitude what did you glean
from talking to alan and mcdermott prior
to this game that makes you think that
that uh if you will they could believe
in miracles you know mom you're using
that line
no i i don't mind using your line i'm
writing this down right now water skiing
behind
yes there you go yes that is that's from
uh wall street that's wall street bud
fox once uh asked uh gordon gekko how
many
yachts can you water ski behind is what
he said in that film oh
i wrote it down you'll hear it on sunday
night next year fantastic
you know it's the old it's the
quarterback coach
combo platter i mean that that's the the
key to success very often in the
national football
you look at obviously with the belichick
and brady
uh being at the forefront of that but
it's almost every year that the
quarterback coach combination
is going to lift the lombardi trophy
last year another case in point
so i think they've got the right combo
platter in in buffalo right now i think
allen's going to be
a big star going down the line he
already is
almost ascending to that point right now
uh
you got sean mcdermott who is the um you
know the pedigree is defense
but you know the great defensive
coordinators know a lot about offense as
well he's got brian davil running
running the offense and it looks like
now that the table is out of the mix for
the charger job but
he might be staying there so they might
be able to keep that that coaching
situation
intact i think the only thing with
buffalo is
can they get a running game uh you've
got devin singletary who
is a pretty good receiver and and not a
bad runner
but he's not the guy who's going to give
you 20 calories
a game and be able to you know run some
clock on you and the other night we saw
what they did
uh i think they you know they had what
one run in the in the first half and
that was a scramble
by allen so it's it's hardly a balanced
offense
but it became more balanced in the
second half to me that's the key with
these guys
uh i think you know offensively they can
do it they just need more balance
defensively you couldn't be more
impressed than you were the other night
i mean
here come the ravens scoring like crazy
how do we stop
lamar jackson you got a couple of good
running backs as well
the receivers have gotten better you
know through through the year you got
andrews of course and then hollywood
brown
uh he was coming um you know into his
own
in the second half of the season and yet
nothing
now i know you know the the weather
conditions uh played a big factor
but i think you know with buffalo
against kansas city
again it reminds me of last week's game
how what will that defense do what will
that defense do to
you know to stop you would think mahomes
is obviously going to play
and the potency of the kansas city
offense we know about that but
what what's leslie frazier and mcdermott
gonna gonna cook up this week that to me
is the key of the game now michael's
here
on the rich eisen show uh i i you're
you're so outstanding
uh at so many broadcasting uh attributes
al but
you're one of your best is to just place
things in perspective
it sure looks like breeze is done uh and
getting ready to join
you and the rest of everyone else at nbc
sports
that's just um based on just his body
language in the way that he was
just looking around at the end of the
game yesterday um
place in perspective where he stands
just in terms of
uh how he got drafted in and then his
change of address and
his physical stature and then his
ultimate football stature i'll give you
the floor on
it is uh when you look at the body of
his career
and his work it's astonishing and he has
to obviously go into the hall of fame
first ballot should be unanimous i can't
imagine anybody saying
we have to wait a year for drew brees to
get in there in addition to the numbers
we know what the numbers are the numbers
are fantastic
but to come into the league as a
second-round draft choice with san diego
and then to be told okay you know
you're our quarterback but we're going
to go out and we're going to draft
eli manning and then manning's not going
to come and of course manning
is then able to work his way to the
giants
and then philip rivers comes in that
deal so now you know philip rivers is
gonna sit behind you
and then off he goes and he's got the
shoulder problem
and as you recall i think it was miami
that passed on him i think he was
hoping to go to miami or wanted to go to
miami yes and free agency right in miami
clearly wanted him but they were worried
about him physically in the new orleans
took the chance
and we we know how that worked out and
then you got katrina on top of it
and the time becomes a mess it looks
like at one
point the league is going to have to
move the franchise out of there
and they don't and they spend a whole
year you know playing in san antonio and
baton rouge
and wherever else they could find a
place to play as the city got rebuilt
and then to come in and win a super bowl
and to do what he's done and and to be
you know such a part of the community
and again you go back to this old
quarterback coach thing
perfect you got sean payton and you got
drew brees so there it is and again you
know i guess the knock would be and
we're knocking everything these days as
you know
the only one one super bowl i mean come
on already so you know they they
you look they can look at it a million
ways to go back to the rams game they
don't make the call on
roby coleman that what would have
happened had they made the call
and they've gone under when the super
bowl you don't know nobody nobody seems
to know
at this point but i would say we would
breeze it's
you look at not only the numbers but the
quality of the individual
uh and it's one of the great stories
i've seen in the national football
league ever
and now we've got also i mean brady and
rogers good lord we've never seen brady
and breeze in the playoff game now it's
the first of brady and rogers which is i
guess the fruits of
of brady moving addresses to the nfc
unbelievable matchup how do you see that
one playing out having seen both of
these guys this year
uh in 2020 first of all i couldn't be
more impressed
than aaron rodgers and what he's done
this year
and we all know the story you go back to
draft day
and he's out in malibu he's got a house
out here
and he's watching the draft
and you're thinking about you know you
got to get him a receiver
some help on offense and what do they do
they picked jordan love the quarterback
and it's so similar of course to when
you know farv is there
and they pick aaron rodgers and
you know we had uh we had aaron in the
uh
next to last game of the season
tennessee against
green bay and lambo and we were talking
to him
and he said on our call he said you know
i could have let
bitterness and negativity seep in
and he did go as he said to the pantry
and get i think what forehands
i think is the measurement of tequila
that's what he did that night so
you you have all of these things in play
what are they doing
are they trying to force me out do i
have to doubt where i am in my career
right now
and instead he took as he said
he could have done he could have gone
one way instead he completely goes the
other way
has one of the most fantastic seasons
ever
totally in control i can't tell you how
much respect i have for him
and you know i mean look rich you know
how smart this guy is
this guy could this guy could replace
alex trebek as the host of jeopardy
he's attempting to i think right he's
going that he's going to fill in for a
week
he was a great contestant on that show
he'll be great on that show
i mean whatever aaron decides to do with
the rest of his life i mean he's going
to be a major success
but i could not be more impressed with
what he's done this year for tom brady i
mean
what a story obviously and you know you
think back rich too
there's always this tremendous
overreaction
on a monday after the sunday games yeah
we did the game
uh middle of the season or i guess it
was maybe
late november we go down to tampa and we
did the new orleans tampa game and the
saints blew them out
it was 33 three at the half whatever it
was
the game was over and brady didn't look
good at all
and everybody said oh you know that tom
may be finished and he and bruce arians
don't get along
right i mean what nonsense does that
look like
right now uh total so it's it's great i
mean you couldn't have a
a better match up a more thrilling
matchup a more
marquee matchup than we're going to get
next sunday and i can't wait to see the
game
both games in fact yeah and i'm sure you
feel the same way me too no doubt about
it now michael's here on the rich eisen
show in the few minutes
i have left i'm gonna go omnibus with
you here which means outside of football
i was thinking of calling you on this
day but i think you were getting ready
for
uh one of your final games of the year
the passing of tommy lasorda
al um i i i know you've got some great
stories
including how uh you first
met him right i think that's from your
book if you can't make this
up i'll give you the floor on your
memories of tommy
tell that one story about how you you
met him well
when i was announcing the hawaiian
islanders in the pacific coast like
aaa baseball starting in 1968 and i was
there three years our big
rival were the spokane indians and they
were the dodger farm club
and the aaa farm club and because of
travel
the indians would come over twice a year
and they'd spend the entire week there
so i got to know steve garvey bobby
valentine
bill russell davey lopes ron say that's
the team
bill buckner all those guys are playing
with the team
and the sword is the manager and then
tommy loves to tell the story it's a
little bit embellished but but
very close to the truth he always has
contented he discovered me
because after every game in hawaii he
would have to call al campanis and the
general manager of the dodgers
and reported on how all of the guys had
done garvey did this
buckner did this lopes did this et
cetera et cetera so one night he says he
tells camp panas he said hey ali should
you know i know you got vince scully and
then he's great everything there's a guy
over here though
that's a young guy doing these games on
the radio this guy is really terrific
al michaels is his name you know you
should keep an eye on him
so campanis doesn't say anything at
first and then at the end of the
conversation according to tommy campana
says
hey tommy this this kid you talking
about this michael's guy
how do you know he's any good and tommy
says i've been thrown out of the last
four games about the clubhouse listening
to him
now in hawaii the clubhouse wasn't
behind the duggar you have to walk all
the way out to center field 425 feet get
serenaded by the fans
and then another hundred feet to a
ramshackle clubhouse you could not sneak
back in
truly you'd have to listen to the radio
so that's the third thing so i know he's
listening to me for seven endings one
night
the next night he's so angry he comes
out he gives the lineup card to the
umpires
he gets thrown out with the lineup and i
already have ironies
you know the matter the the off the
umpire home plate that night was bruce
framing
who would go on to have the longest
empowering career in major league
history amazing he would go to the major
so this is crazy stuff he gets thrown
out again now he's listening to me the
whole game
the next game he did last he lasted the
game and then the following game he got
thrown out like the six or seven thing
so tommy truly was able to hear me do
you know probably 20 innings of baseball
and so uh he always loved to tell that
story of course
i love the fact that tommy was such a
big part of he was
just a wonderful man on so many levels
so many and just
uh i mean an ambassador a character
and and a damn good manager
hall of fame manager former teammate of
jackie robinson's with the brooklyn
dodgers like a true dodger
through and through al yeah and so so he
says basically that's how you got your
first
major league broadcasting gig
he goes them he goes as a coach under
walt austin
with the dodger tommy and i went all the
way back and
in fact when i got a nice honor about
six or seven years ago i
i had tommy come up and and presented
for me so and
and i'll tell you another thing too he
was in the hospital
and i got the ford frick award recently
it was totally congratulations totally
surprising and shocking and
and wonderful for me and
he called me yeah his caretaker
called me and said can you talk to tommy
of course
this was about a month ago he did not
sound well but it was it was
unbelievable to hear from tommy lasorda
and i was i was so happy when i heard
that he was out of the hospital but
clearly he had
been taken home to die at home and um
one of a kind what a what a wonderful
wonderful man you're the best al
thanks for the call let's uh let's let's
uh stay in touch let's go
have uh a good uh a good round or two if
you will
at least maybe maybe 10 or 12 right
let's do it al uh
you're the best thanks the call take
care you got that sound michaels
everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here